we begin this half-hour with the growing
influence of women in politics the
inauguration of Donald Trump one year
ago today prompted women's marches
around the world last year a CBS News
poll finds women are still dissatisfied
with the president 63 percent disapprove
of the president's handling of his job
half say his policies have hurt women
and 82% say it's important that more
women are elected to office Paula Reid
is at the Lincoln Memorial where this
year's women's March is set to kick off
later today Paula good morning good
morning that's right the women's March
returns here to Washington DC and many
other cities across the country today
but they're not expecting those same
record crowds that we saw last year but
organizers tell me they're not focused
on crowd size they were focused on
winning elections a day after president
Trump's inauguration millions of women
donned pink hats and marched in protest
this year it's less about matching hats
and more about midterm elections
organizers have dubbed it power to the
polls we are really encouraging people
to go vote in in November of 2018 Sarah
Sophie flicker is a national organizer
for the women's March we will absolutely
be registering voters getting out the
vote knocking on doors having you know
conversations with people one-on-one
about why it's so important to vote the
effort is working EMILY's List a women's
march sponsor coaches democratic women
on running for office they have trained
more than 26,000 women to run for local
state and national office over the last
year but the women's March has come
under criticism for only representing
the views of liberal women Rachel
Simmons was one of tens of thousands of
women at the other big march in
Washington Friday's marked for life
she says the women's March excludes
pro-life women there is a blatant
hypocrisy in the type of women the
women's march once and they're not a
March or a movement about empowerment
they're a movement about picking women
the only agree with them Flickr denies
the women's March is an event
exclusively for Democrats the March was
a demonstration against a Republican
president and it's now turned into a
movement to get Democrats elected so is
it fair to say the women's March is a
partisan event I wouldn't say that it's
partisan but I would say if you look at
this administration like who
predominantly makes up this
administration white men and I think
what I can say about the women's March
is that it represents women's interests
and that's not partisan or nonpartisan
organizers will wrap this weekend's
marches with a big event in Las Vegas
tomorrow they chose that location
because it's in a state where Hillary
Clinton defeated President Trump by a
razor-thin margin so it symbolizes how
every vote counts especially this year
Alex Paula Reid in Washington thanks
Paula the early numbers show that there
is going to be a surfeit and historic
high in terms of female candidates yeah
that's gonna be very interesting that
the March last year was one of the most
extraordinary things I've ever seen the
spirit and the turnout was truly amazing
the interesting see what happens this
year